that time we talk a badge the real first
person shooter oh yeah
battlefield baby ok battlefield what a
series know what I thought you're gonna
say you are way you can say half-light
over why some poor talk about later yeah
we're talking about you've been playing
i mean i'll another futuristic shooter
yes yes exactly the future where we have
god please dummy anthropomorphised apes
who are able to I mean nape so pretty
I'm throw four more fights already
really aren't they yeah yeah that's the
one thing that we all going for them you
Apes want to live forever
bring me the spaceman and no we're gonna
talk about battlefield a storage video
game franchise no no no no get rid of
the story why don't you you don't need a
story
yes but forking it done one of my
favorite long lasting memories of this
franchise was mouth of Vietnam saying
that it was a campaign on the back of
the box and then there wasn't yeah no
clicks to talk about in a menu replaced
that instant action BOTS instead so
let's have a chat we're all fans of the
Battlefield series here I thought it
would be a fun time because we don't
really know what they're going to
announce on Thursday so there's no point
in us like talking about it and but we
can't talk about is our love of the
games past and sort of what is like the
best battlefield game the series started
back in I guess it was was at $19.99 no
2002 about for 1942 and which now looks
like an iPhone game it's amazing scrape
if you fire that up I think it's free on
or agenor it was for a while right yeah
because the draw distance that they had
to calculate in that game for the time
was so much longer than you would think
so like this is all these crummy pixel
people yeah shooting patch yeah and we
found it out when Iron I fell in love
with the series so I played I played a
little bit of to just because back then
yeah pcs were expensive and I didn't
have a lot of money at that time and the
first very accessible battlefield game
was bad company and bad company 2 yes
which is kind of where I've really fell
in love with it but I completely
understand that the generation of people
who played battlefield 2 on PC who could
afford pcs at that time yeah they fell
in love with the open conquest
just freedom of that game so it's weird
over the years between that bad company
and battlefield
like hardline and God 3 they've they've
cast their net so wide then I don't know
if they can please all of the people
that they've like captured yeah I mean
when I think about a great battlefield
game you know 1942 was so much fun back
then the desert combat mod was so
popular as well big fan of that which
was basically sort of I think the main
reason battlefield 2 went in the
direction it did and you're right like
battlefield 2 was the game which for me
that that was the reason to upgrade your
PC like that was when online
connectivity in Ireland as well got like
to a stage where you could play online
so when we weren't playing like games
like counter-strike at 1.6 and then
eventually CS source like battlefield 2
was like a game that like got your
processor to like kick in and also was a
fun online class space shooter were like
big maps and stuff and but my favorite
game in the series still hands down is
both with Vietnam I absolutely thought a
games you played on one Mike oh yeah
that was so I got into the series with a
desert combat the mod my brother was
playing it and then he got to on his PC
so I started playing that and I really
got into it like with Vietnam bed
company obviously not around the same
time but those were the first two that
were really mine not like bright
something I was it was they weren't
hand-me-down so those are the first two
I really got into start realizing how
much I liked the series and how how much
I liked how it set itself apart from
other games this I mean there's a
certain like feeling you have when
you're flying Huey and Creedence is
playing oh yeah changing the radio
station for like oh I think I'll listen
to like deep purple now yeah that sounds
about right
I think Vietnam if they did go that
direction and I'm concerned they won't
because of all the other near future
rhymes out right now and video game
studios are a lot like film studios
where like they'll sort of do what
they're good their competitors are doing
like yeah but if they did Vietnam in
which it would check a lot of the boxes
like the photogrammetry from battlefront
is gorgeous and they can do force really
well although they haven't proven they
can do photogrammetry with destruction
which I'm concerned about but yeah like
a Vietnam game would have asymmetrical
warfare
it would have mild customization it
would have photogrametry you would look
gorgeous
it would have Vespas yep yeah would have
that humour yeah you're right though
that asymmetrical multiplayer is
something that we sort of haven't had in
in one of these mainstream multiplayer
shooters in quite a while now so much
fun like putting like
gee sticks in and yeah having like
respawn points like pop up all over the
place so I think it would be a good
direction they're listening to Reddit
they would go world war ii which rice
i'm still not convinced people want
world war ii but there has been 10 years
of people who maybe grew up without
world war ii yes didn't didn't sit there
and play only world war ii games for a
decade yeah so i don't know that one's a
mixed bag I'm not sure I mean I grew up
on World War two games I'm I'm ready for
war ii guess well as long as they're
sort of they're they're they're handled
effectively and so we've talked about -
we talked about vietnam we've talked
about 1942 as much as I'd love to talk
about bad company next we should
actually talk about 2142 which is one
that a lot of people forget about
Michael nodding your head design
appreciation or the opposite it's I have
no idea I've played it for about five
total hours of friend's house down the
street while when I was still pretty
busy like playing you know desert combat
like one of my brother's old PC and
stuff I don't know I I remember playing
it I remember in it feeling weird I
wasn't used that futuristic setting that
aesthetic and it kind of I knew as a
battlefield game but I wasn't really
used to the whole like shifting between
these settings too much so it was very
weird experience I don't remember much
of it it had this crazy mode who's
actually interesting because you get it
there you can get in slide mechs and I
had a mode called titan mode yeah do you
remember this it was the like flying
space station or you had to get up and
was either take it out or capture it I
think it's a put a bomb in us or
something so there was like that it was
like a space station that was like I
guess that final capture point on a
series of capture points and then yeah
you'd have to go up and basically stick
a bomb who did that better
who's Star Wars Battlefront oh yeah it's
true I'm 21 42 is interesting when I
feel like it maybe went in a direction
like it did the future warfare thing
back when people didn't want future
warfare and I think it probably suffered
from it and so very people were very
happy when Battlefield Bad Company came
around and this is kind of thought as as
the game that didn't really sell very
well but if you like I have never met
anyone who played battlefield bad comedy
who doesn't love this game that game was
designed you know I've followed david
goldfarb and right he was one of the
lead designers on that game and he's
always talked about how that game was
designed to be more like the Indiana
Jones inspired Battlefield Rush and I
think it showed it was the first one
that just wasn't
generic mix soldier dude one of the best
things about that game was once you got
past a certain point you could just stop
and the guys on your bound bad company
would start talking and I would say
really hilarious [ __ ] like smell very
clean like he's like I don't I think I'm
an angry man cuz my mom used too much
deep when I was a kid I like you know
they they just had these guys sit in the
studio I don't know how long rice two
hours and just talk it's just it was so
good and like it took place in World War
two and it took place in the present and
like one or two of the levels were we're
open like you drove across this giant
desert and to three different bases and
um you could like if you found an ammo
crate you could just like lay waste to
the rest of the building just for shits
and giggles basically and that was like
going back that was the game that got a
lot of people off of Call of Duty like
that was the first game that really
appealed to the Call of Duty crowd well
that was a game that had hey look you
can add a funny interesting stories with
a story with likable characters who you
will remember in a World War 2 game I
like oh no in a what way no World War 2
game but just in a first-person military
game I don't think anyone's done as
better since like Battle of feedback
company 2 was wonderful as well the
catch was you had to love Rush which
which I do why I love that game so much
I think it didn't necessarily scratch
the conquest itch that a lot of the
battlefield 2 people had and that's
again like you've got two very different
audiences you've got people who
passionately love Rush and every in the
linear ness
that those levels bring and then you
have people who passionately love just
the hands off here's my toolbox and a
large open map yeah let's go play some
conquest so you need to appeal to both
of those audiences to have a successful
battlefield game and after data and
battlefield 3 came out in the end of
2011 and this was basically the time
where EA sort of clapped their hands
again and said okay enough is enough
we're not gonna be the second you know
they also ran in the mills you
first-person-shooter were going for and
Call of Duty's throat it had the same
sort of battlefield to you know
super-powerful PC aspect to it obviously
came in on consoles as well which the
bad company series had as well and I
guess bad feds who also came out on xbox
or something but
this was the first time they'd sort of
like really pushed it and which I'm not
sure if there's a PhD version about it
for two maybe there was I feeling that
there might have been it was a weird
time first first years back then and but
what did you think of about fit three
Mike will you find that one at all
I remember them pushing really hard for
the fact that I was gonna have that
story-driven campaign and at this point
in playing games I was I was primarily
like playing for single-player and I
knew battlefield wasn't like the thing I
was expecting a single-player story from
but I played that and I couldn't stand
that single-player it was it was called
duty it was crazy a divisive that is
because for some reason I loved it oh
really and I don't think but I don't
really know why I loved maybe it's just
cuz I just played black ops 2 or
whatever came out that year and the
black ops games I actually liked their
campaigns their stories but um I'm not
French level the Paris level which is
actually very difficult to play now post
what happened last summer and I thought
that was like one of the most amazingly
atmospheric that and the the jet plane
one where you went off of the de mission
and came by remember that the Paris one
or everything of Paris I think a modern
warfare 3 when the chemical attacks hit
and ok that's saying something because
my warfare was a four-hour campaign
right remember anything yeah but yeah I
don't know battlefield 3 I played a lot
of multiplayer I would just come off you
know like the last one I played a lot
was Battlefield Bad Company 2 and I just
like you - I love those games and 3 I
think kind of was scratching that same
kind of itch that I needed to get away
from call of duty with so it came around
it a good time because even then I think
Call of Duty exhaustion was setting in
um and three kind of you know gave me
that that more nuanced multiplayer angle
I was looking for yeah baby
and things lavalla didn't they are good
Geel evolved I don't know man like that
I did love three how many I want to
catch this as a first of all how many
hours you think you put in the pilot
feel 3 over 200 yeah I mean I'm I'm
somebody who burns out after about the
one to two hundred hour mark right
that's like I'll just get that feeling
like you've ate too much candy at that
point and I just no matter how much I
want to keep playing I can't but I have
AI know people who could put a thousand
hours into that game easy um three was
great I loved it I thought it did
exactly what it needed to do the
multiplayer I think it did have great
rush Maps and it did have great conquest
maps Caspian borders
like I still love that just maybe mostly
because of the aesthetic yeah well yeah
it's just some really memorable maps I
think even their large conquest maps
conceptually were good the armored kill
expansion was also really fun like
banned art desert was massive and fun
and like had so many different aspects
to it and and their DLCs aftermath was
thematically very strong it has Gavin
germ ode which was really fun in
battlefield so it was just there's so
much done right with that game it had
the epic parachute jump on Damavand peak
oh yeah my god that's so good just
cannot believe that they didn't do in
for right like how do you not love a
thousand-foot parachute drop and then
you know mean you got some guy up there
with like the the Barret like firing all
the way down to the bottom of the map
you know it's just there are so many
great memorable moments from threes
multiplayer and in a like terrain
highway like it was a night map that you
like went from fought through a town at
night and then you fought into a city
like again that was the rush influenced
yeah for came around and they're like
screw it we're just gonna put everything
on every map and everything was so bland
to be of it like rush crates were just
haphazardly put wherever the hell
somebody decided they're gonna get put
sometimes you would like run across a
map and then run back across the map and
then run to it like there was just no
like slow or anything like Caspian
border when is remade in battlefield 4
oh yeah one of the conquest points was a
ditch why it's like why do I ditch it
strategic value why do I may not
understand as somebody who actually you
have had military yeah one person here
and I'm also I guess the other problem
you could say what that was you know
this was a game that had a lot of
multiplayer of problems with
connectivity throughout its lifetime as
well and what I hazard to ask but in a
new battlefield I'm guessing one of the
things you would like would be for
Battlelog to just disappear forever
uh there are aspects of Battlelog that
are good the ability to go in and futz
with your character when you're on the
bus somewhere is great like everybody
loves to do that that games less fussing
yeah games like the division I was blown
away they didn't have a nap
well I'd you know destiny had an app I
was just always messing around with my
character and that the ability to to
think about and engage with a game when
you're not playing it is always a plus
hmm launching the game was a whole
nother thing
like all that battlelog did was put a
barrier between me and playing the game
right and I cannot tell you how many
times it literally took me 20 minutes to
get my first game of the night launched
because I had to patch battle log and
then restart restart and then it was on
the wrong browser and then it wasn't
compatible with a browser setting and
then like it the browser return was
confusing like was it mean if I checked
none was it if I don't check none like
am i getting proper return on on the
search that I put in yeah it was always
and then you would get it to load and it
would take five minutes yeah I timed it
one time it took me fight it took me
five minutes to get into the test server
it's crazy so the these are just
barriers that don't need to exist just
get rid of them and and get let players
hit start and get into a match let's
briefly talk about the I guess the sort
of side games her son in the chat making
a good point battlefield to modern
combat I actually totally forgot about
this a totally different game to
Battlefield 2 single-player campaign II
actually really enjoyed it a lot did you
bet on me too for very different reasons
I like the other games but I remember
getting into that and I didn't even know
what it was really when my friend told
me to play it because I had been a you
know big fan of battlefield 2 I knew
what that was all about a knew why I
played it all the time for a couple
years and my combat was more it was it
was just this like wide scale
single-player missions yeah and I
remember and they were they were
well-designed I think it was actually a
good game for what I was going for is
like tank commissions in their share
country stuff and yeah it was a good
balance between their like the halo
balance between vehicles and or I guess
the back the battlefield between
vehicles and foot combat it wasn't what
I was expecting from the franchise but
what it was going for I think it nailed
doesn't doesn't look too hot now when
you check out some of the footage but
yeah still a memorable game and we also
had battlefield 1943 which was the
interesting digital-only
version of like a sort of a pseudo
sequel to 1942 which had a bunch of like
Wake Island and a couple of other
Maps in there as well it was alright I'd
like other battlefields that one gave
you these really like weirdly satisfying
rewards right for doing anything it's
kind of like one of those like yes like
Shane's right it was just like you'd
like snipe some guy across the map and
you'd get one of those Call of Duty like
you're awesome
okay um you know whatever there was only
six weapons it was very simplistic there
was tons of like terrain deformation I
think it's it was it wasn't meant to be
played for a very long period of time
yeah but it was a lot of fun like wallet
was there and then the last game to talk
about I don't think we probably missed
one or two here I know there was a bunch
of expansion packs for these games we we
haven't gotten into secret weapons of
World War two actually the expansion
pack for 1942 was really tremendous and
worth a little mention but yeah let's
talk about briefly the game which opts
to allow you to just go you're arrested
put any gun yeah battlefield hardline
and if fans here I didn't play much of
it at all I played ten hours right I
thought I remember the initial reveal
trailer it was weird I'm showing that
trailer with the stuff that was going on
what two years ago yes it was very
strange it was nice for Tom Ozzy's odd
tastes and uh still A's I'm like on the
front pages so they should have gone way
more heavily into place brutality they
took the easy way out
John I wonder actually if that was part
of it was that they were born for this
Hawaii five-o woohoo were just cops
doing whatever and then when oh no no we
should I would someone will write a
story about Don the future I'm sure sure
but in terms of have a plate any fights
you play much you're an iron I know I
really enjoyed a lot of things that
visceral did with that game they
actually fixed a lot of dices problems
there was some coding issues like sound
through floor bugs that always bugged
battlefield three people like you
couldn't tell what floor somebody was on
when they were running around or hit me
so you'd hear somebody running at you
and you'd like get your gun up and then
it turns out they were a floor above you
like visceral actually fix a lot of
those problems they brought a lot of
humor to the game the zip line and the
downtown map I thought were fantastic
like if you multiplayer actually did a
bunch of interest if you take any
individual element of what they did I
love it like they have these really
funny one in 10,000 like animations when
you take it as a whole package I think
there wasn't
enough of it and it had gone through two
betas and then kind of a suffering from
beta fatigue right and there wasn't
enough content beyond that to really
hold people's attention I also think
that they should have done
they shouldn't have they should have
done some battlefield maps like a lot of
the mouse were very tight urban maps and
they felt like they could have been
about twice as big as they were and I
think they lost the core battlefield
crowd just because none of the maps
really felt like battlefield and you
wouldn't have had to have done all of
them like maybe half of them right and
the other half are urban but it's sort
of picked the sod and stuck with us for
better or for worse and yeah that's
actually true I was kind of harsh on the
single-player aspect that you write the
multiple axis stuff was was pretty good
for a while it was enjoyable there
wasn't enough of it and they didn't do
enough of core battlefield stuff to
basically bring in the larger audience
which I think was sad because I think
they really did do a lot of fun little
things and the one thing that I they
better bring into all the all the rest
of the Battlefield franchise is the the
unlock tree from hardline right where
you just like earn currency and you just
buy whatever you want what you want yeah
like I do not want to spend another 200
hours trying to get my ECM jammer
unlocked to my jet while getting my butt
handed to me by like senior jet pilots
and it's just not fun to play with a new
gun and forget you just get killed
because you have to start with iron
sights it's just that they need to take
from that game crazy franchise it's been
around a long time
I guess not time not long 14 years
probably shy of 14 years at this stage
but some tremendous games in there I
really hope that whatever they show on
Thursday sort of lives up to some of the
games that we talked about here because
there's been a half-dozen absolute gems
like classics in terms of first-person
shooters let's go around the table final
thoughts what is your favorite
battlefield game Michael my Hardy I
think I'll stick to the route to the
battlefield - okay yeah although I'm I'm
sure you might be saying when I was
thinking of as well but yeah battlefield
2 is where I got into it it's when I
really started playing a multiplayer
game you know cuz like counter-strike
and now we have not comparing
counter-strike to Call of Duty right but
now we have Call of Duty it's that
fast-paced twitchy just kind of lacking
in substance whereas battlefield
said like every time you do a
multiplayer match yet like some crazy
story to tell afterwards press press
just medkits yeah that exact every
couple of seconds make it you want to
make it that was it and I would just run
around like an idiot throwing these
these you know MREs at people uh yeah
that would that was a battlefield to for
me what about yourself right predictably
bad company to but I will say if dice
doesn't hate money they should just do
an HD remaster battlefield two because a
lot of their great maps in three
we're just remakes of battlefield two
maps and I think people would absolutely
buy HD battlefield 2 yeah just we
release it I would yeah give me a ticket
for an airplane
I just love vaudeville VIN of so much
it's like it goes down as one of my fate
I was in a clam I was in on IG Irish
Guards take I was there QE pilot for a
bed a year or so and I was like I don't
know 14 or something and I love that you
could even just like put your own mp3s
in a folder I just like play whatever
the hell you wanted so I just be like
flying in with like Deftones playing or
something their helmet lopsidedness
trapped exactly a huge glasses are
fogged up it was so much fun we'd spawn
and everyone would get in the Huey and
you'd basically like shut --all across
the landscape there hug the flag cuz all
like six of you or whatever five of you
are in it and we go tick tick tick tick
tick tick tick yeah and then go to the
next one and then like to be a battle of
0.3 between two enemy here he's yeah and
everyone would jump by when they thought
was kind of splode it's like one of the
most memorable experiences for me ever
so yeah yeah probably Vietnam for me
classic games let us know what you think
is your favorite battlefield or what
just is your favorite battlefield and
what is the best battlefield and what
would you like from battlefield 4 in the
comments
sorry battlefield 4 battlefield 5 or
whatever an unmanned just battlefield
battlefield you're going to go back to
the start and
on this play